you'll be affected as well for the most
part you know I know there's a lot of
things that you know I've been tested
for and I know a lot of things going on
that you know I need to be compensated
for for his insurance from NFL but since
I've been retired God honest truth that
I know at the NFL the lawyers that work
for the NFL you know they make it so
hard you know to be assessed for
yourself to be taken care of after
playing for 11 plus years whatever 12
years you would think that it would be a
lot easier and there be more
compensating and willing to take care of
us as players but it's not you know it's
a doggone shame I say that you know not
the words I really want to say but it's
a shame that the way it's set up that
they make it so hard for us after
football to be taken care of you know
everybody we put our lives on the line
for these organizations we play so hard
we give everything physically you know
we got guys passing away you know years
before their time and concussions and
all this we've got kids flowing nearly
you know now football and be saying play
football but we not taking care of our
players out there you know so that's
been the most discouraging thing and but
I'm still taking care of myself thank
God I got my health my mind you know at
38 and still able to throw the ball and
hang with my son and spend time with the
family and travel and yeah I got
finances but you know it's more to find
that you talking about life so but I you
know I know Steve bisciotti and what he
thinks to you and he would do anything
for you I'd but the question was so
what's the dish there's not just a
Ravens it's not Steve bisciotti that
you're going to talk to to say hey I had
an injury you don't take care of me it's
not Steve bisciotti going through this
in the NFL you know and and and their
lawyers you know and their lawyers are
not working with you they don't want to
pay you there's a reason why we get
fined away we get fine there's a reason
why they take your money where they take
your money you know there's a reason why
it's not the NFL is not the players
league you know and what you should be
you know we don't want to put all the
things on the line you know you'd a made
your billions you know it's not about
the own it's not
it's not to take away from the Amish you
know they do a lot too but we got to
start taking care of our players you got
to start taking care of the players you
know us at the University of Miami
alumni I said in a Salesman I just lost
you know Cortes kidney at 48 you know we
don't know the reason why yet but come
on come on come on now so we need to do
something we need to do something or
just gonna go on forever come on man
well in terms of our today's is what is
he doing what is the Union when you call
up the Union sent and actually I
actually never really got into the Union
because I'm not a political guy don't do
politics you know and I notice a lot of
BS that's going through there because
I've had people I know who worked in
there you know Dominique rocks work
being one yeah and I know a lot of guys
would work through there so I just know
I know from being in the league I know
from being at universe mine before I
came to school stay in school five years
because I knew the legal to business and
a31 a very cutthroat business so there's
a lot of things that need to be changed
there's a lot of great things that the
NFL - I'm not by the system tell you we
don't do a lot of great things but the
bad things that we do in the to bad and
you can see it too bad because you have
so many older guys that's passing away
you know so I need the NFLPA I need to
end b8p a leader I can't think of her
name right now to be the NFLPA
leader and do the things that she's
doing for the NBA build a facility where
NFL players can go if they don't have it
not sure but allocate money for the
older guys allocate money for the older
guys to get it set by doctors that we
pay for take money out it only come on
man we're getting millions to guys
who've never performed it took me years
years to get out their first contract
and try to get paid and all that stuff
it take come on man
so that stuff we can do those things we
can do to make our league a lot better a
lot of a lot more
protective but we don't reach out to
guys like me we release guys like we
release the older guys so we can get
younger guys in here as we want to these
younger guys don't have leaders to look
up to or to talk to to guide them to
help them to be responsible smart off
the field on the field players men
contribute to society the way we should
and not getting as much trouble but we
rather put us on a pedestal first and
then slam us when we do something and
not let us play not give us a second
chance of life so it's a lot of catch-22
a lot of things that are wrong in our
society you know a lot of things that
are on NFL us as a society because the
NFL is truly a representation of the
people at rejoin your representation
we're representation of the people who
have big brother no no sorry no I'm
fascinated with what you've got to say
it and I do I also want to get into what
you are doing in your hometown of New
Orleans in terms of giving back I want
to get that in but I also just want to
make sure I had read here on the show
seems like you're putting both the Union
and the league on blast right here as
you're sitting in a doctor's me it's
just information that need to be told it
ain't so much as blasting them and I
fell because I love I love my game I get
up and play right now I play it for life
but we need to do more we need to do
more as a country I could put the
country on blast but then I'm Colin
Kaepernick and I'm not right but is he
wrong he's not wrong so I'm not putting
us on blast I'm blasting the information
that needs to be out there public
service announcement to young kids that
play this game parents that got their
kids playing this game
the owners does leading his league the
commissioner who is the faith president
of this league of this country we need
the people behind them that support
come on now or nothing's enough let's
start making the right changes the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience if you like that video be sure
to download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to